hey ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
spezielles thema auf meinem kanal und
zwar der valentinstag ich muss ehrlich
sein für mich und haben sie das gar kein
thema denn das ist für uns ein tag wie
jeder andere
aber was los letztes jahr waren wir in
der waschstraße fand abgeben einkaufen
was haben wir noch pappkartons weg
gebracht also ganz viele sachen erledigt
also wie gesagt das ist wirklich ein tag
wie jeder andere für uns aber ich weiß
dass einige das auch so ein bisschen
nehmen um den liebsten zu sagen was wir
empfinden und das kann man auch gerne
machen deswegen hab ich gedacht heute
zeige ich euch meine idee wir machen
nämlich eine richtig schöne bizkit rolle
als herz also eine herznote quasi sicher
ganz durcheinander
jetzt fangen wir am besten mal direkt an
mit den zutaten für den teig news
beliebt so wir benötigen eier auf
zimmertemperatur warmes wasser außerdem
zucker mehl und speisestärke backpulver
1 prise salz und vanille extrakt oder
vanille zucker um jetzt einen lockeren
teig zu erhalten werden wir die eier
richtig schön aufschlagen
wir geben die prise salz dazu dass hier
noch mal so ein bisschen den süßen
geschmack und das lauwarme wasser hat
das hilft einfach dass die eier so
richtig schön dick schaumig geschlagen
werden können
und an der stelle gebe ich auch noch das
zucker dazu das bewegt einfach dass die
eier so ein bisschen fester sind wenn
sie dann schau mich sind das ganze dann
auf höchster stufe ich nehme die
küchenmaschine dort mit der
küchenmaschine so acht minuten ihr könnt
auch ein handrührgerät verwenden dann
sind es ungefähr so 10 11 minuten
[Musik]
so die eier sind jetzt richtig schön
dick schaumig geschlagen und jetzt kommt
noch die trockenen zutaten dazu und dann
nehmt ihr euch auf jeden fall ein sieg
dann wird das ganze nämlich richtig
schön locker und ihr könnt auch vorher
schon dass vanille extrakt dazu gibt das
habe ich dann auch gemacht oder eben
vanillezucker
[Musik]
ganz zügig gehen jetzt die schüssel
zurück in die maschine und jetzt ruhig
nur auf langsame stufe ganz kurz und so
lange bis sich die trockenen zutaten mit
der restlichen masse verbunden haben
[Musik]
so ein paar sekunden später ist der tag
auch schon fertig übrigens immer wenn
ich langsame stufe sagt dann meine ich
niedrige stufe sei egal er sich der was
ich meine noch mal schauen ob sich alles
verbunden hat genau und die jetzt kommt
unser backblech zum einsatz da habe ich
nach einem backblech schon vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich ein backpapier
untendrunter gesehen das ist ganz
wichtig dass nichts an klebt und genau
einfach ein bug drum drumherum nehmen
nach den schönen geraden abschluss wer
keinen hat dass es auch kein problem und
nicht den teig ganz einfach darauf
verteilen
[Musik]
so den teig verstreicht er jetzt noch
schön glatt und dann kommt eine
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze dauert es in der regel so
zehn bis zwölf minuten bis er richtig
schön goldbraun ist
sobald der ofen pete müsst ihr ganz
zügig arbeiten diesmal dürften nämlich
nichts in der backform auskühlen lassen
so wie ich sonst immer sagen wenn ich
entferne jetzt erstmal den bug ring und
dann stürzen wir im bizkit sofort so als
nächstes nimmt ihr euch ein sauberes
küchentuch und legt es auf eure
arbeitsfläche und darüber streuen wir
jetzt weißen zucker
so und jetzt nehmen wir uns den heißen
bis geboten einmal runter vom wachsen
und dann einfach auf das küchentuch
stürzen
[Musik]
so und damit der teig jetzt auch von
oben nicht austrocknen nimmt euch ganz
einfach küchentuch einmal unter dem
wasserhahn halten aus bringen und dann
auf dem bizkit boden ging und jetzt muss
er vollständig ausfüllen und dann machen
wir weiter
sobald der bis geboten ausgekühlt ist
kümmern wir uns voll und ganz den
leckeren füllung und dafür habe ich
schon so ein paar zutaten vorbereitet
und zwar benötigen wir die kalte
schlagsahne
doch drum frischkäse außerdem magerquark
puderzucker und johannes beermann
geladen hier habe ich noch seine fest
und vanille extrakt wir schlagen jetzt
zuallererst die sahne steif und dann
müsst ihr ein paar sachen beachten und
zwar durch die sahne ganz kalt ist also
frisch ist im kühlschrank kommt dass
eure schüssel kalt ist und auch er
schneebesen aussetzt kalt ist also das
ist ganz wichtig so die sahne habe ich
jetzt in eine ausreichend große schüssel
gegeben macht jetzt mit meinem
handrührgerät weiter natürlich geht auch
die küchenmaschine aber für so eine
geringe menge lohnt sich das einfach
nicht und ich lag da sitzt und gibt dann
nach und nach zwei teelöffel seine fest
dazu
[Musik]
so die sahne ist steif geschlagen gebe
ich jetzt ganz kurz an die seite und wir
machen weiter mit den restlichen zutaten
dafür nehme ich mir einfach eine neue
schüssel und gibt da alle zutaten rein
und nix das einmal ganz kurz durch
[Musik]
und die zutaten habe ich jetzt auch nur
ca 30 sekunden miteinander vermixt war
es auch schon gleich vereinen wir sahne
mit der anderen cremen aber ich gebe
jetzt erst mal noch ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe hinein einfach für die
optik das müsst ihr nicht aber das könnt
ihr gerne machen
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehmt ihr euch euren
teixeira und sobald die
lebensmittelfarbe auch schon
untergerührt wurde hebt jetzt vorsichtig
in zwei bis drei schritten die sonne
unter
[Musik]
die schöne rose eine creme ist jetzt
fertig und die schmeckt richtig gut sage
ich euch und jetzt widmen wir uns fehler
den bizkit boden der ist nämlich
vollständig ausgekühlt jetzt ziemlich
einfach hier die küchenpapier ab und
dann gebe ich ganz einfach die creme auf
dem bizkit boden und stress erst mal nur
glatt so die creme habe ich jetzt drauf
verstrichen und das ist einfacher wenn
ihr euch oben und unten so ein
zentimeter frei lässt ist passt einfach
dann später besser mit dem herz muster
und jetzt kommt auch schon der
spannendste teil für heute wir wickeln
das jetzt auf und zwar nicht so wie eine
normale rolle sondern von der seite zur
hälfte und von der anderen seite zwölfte
ich zeige euch das am besten mal
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann beide enden zur mitte
hin geräumt habt einfach nochmal
zusammenklappen und ihr seht ganz wie
von alleine bildet sich dann das herz
und dann schneidet ihr natürlich nachher
noch stücke runter kühl zeit braucht es
jetzt nicht mehr
aber wenn ihr das aufbewahren wollte auf
jeden fall in frischhaltefolie verpackt
ihr wisst ja diskutiert wird sonst ein
bisschen hart und trocken und das wollen
wir nicht denn jetzt ist noch richtig
schön weich so und das war es auch schon
ich betreue die biskuitrolle nur noch
mit puderzucker mehr braucht es nicht
das design sieht schon hübsch genug auf
ihr seht mit ganz wenig material kann
man das richtig toll zaubern wenn das
ganze jetzt nach machen möchte dann
schaut und nehmen die infobox das
schreibe ich euch wie man die genauen
mengenangaben die anleitung findet ihr
hier bei mir und dann seid ihr gewappnet
und könnt ihr euren liebsten machen ob
valentinstag oder nicht zu valentinstag
ist ganz euch überlassen wenn ihr meinen
kanal kostenlos abonniert würde es mich
natürlich sehr freuen
dem video ein dummchen nach oben gibt
mir ein kommentar hinterlassen macht ihr
was besonderes an valentinstag erzählt
doch mal würde mich sehr interessieren
wie gesagt bei uns ist ein ganz normaler
tag
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr auch im
nächsten mal dabei seid auf dieses
kitchen tschüss
[Musik]